When you get a bunch of big Hollywood stars
together, there's bound to be some tension.
Even if their characters are getting along
on-screen, the actors behind the scenes don't
always see eye to eye.
Here are a few actors who just couldn't stand
working together.
Dustin Hoffman and Meryl Streep
Dustin Hoffman and Meryl Streep's working
relationship on the set of the Oscar-winning
film Kramer vs. Kramer played out a lot like
the divorced couple they were playing on screen.
Over the years, Streep has been vocal about
the intensity that Hoffman brought to each
scene, which often startled her, and sometimes
downright scared her.
Streep told CBS News just how far Hoffman
would go on set:
"In another scene he sapped me and when you
I see the movie I see the imprint of his hand
on the thing."
She added:
"I think [Hoffman is] very, very gifted, [but]
it wasn't the most fun I've ever had on film."
Yeah, no kidding.
James Franco and Tyrese Gibson
Much like Meryl Streep, Tyrese Gibson wasn't
happy with the intense physicality that co-star
James Franco brought to the set of 2006's
Annapolis, particularly when it came to shooting
the film's big boxing match.
Gibson described the experience to Elle magazine.
"Whenever we'd have to get in the ring for
boxing scenes, and even during practice, the
dude was full-on hitting me."
Franco later apologized for his behavior,
telling GQ, "I was probably a jerk.
I was not purposely cruel to him, but I was
probably so wrapped up in my performance that
I was not as friendly as I could have been."
Charlize Theron and Tom Hardy
Charlize Theron and Tom Hardy had a love-hate
relationship on the set of George Miller's
2015 dystopian epic, Mad Max: Fury Road.
Okay, make that a hate-hate relationship.
The Oscar-winning actress put it bluntly in
an interview with Esquire, saying that she
and Hardy "f***ing went at it" on the set.
"It was the isolation, and the fact that we
were stuck in a rig for the entire shoot.
We shot a war movie on a moving truck — there's
very little green screen.
It was like a family road trip that just never
went anywhere.
We never got anywhere.
We just drove.
We drove into nothingness, and that was maddening
sometimes."
She also added that even though the actors
"drove each other crazy," they still had an
immense amount of respect for one another.
Hardy even left her a semi-sentimental note
after it was done, which read, "You are an
absolute nightmare, BUT you are also f***ing
awesome.
I'll kind of miss you.
Love, Tommy."
Tom Hardy and Shia LaBeouf
Hardy's history of beefing with co-stars didn't
start with Theron.
He also reportedly got in a fist fight with
Shia LaBeouf on the set of 2012's Lawless
— which LaBeouf apparently won.
Hardy himself later admitted as much, although
his description of the fight sounded a little
tongue-in-cheek:
"He knocked me out sparko.
Out cold.
He's a bad, bad boy.
He is.
He's quite intimidating as well.
He's a scary dude...he just attacked me.
He was drinking moonshine."
For his part, LaBeouf claimed the liquor had
nothing to do with his aggression toward Hardy,
telling MTV that their on-set battle "wasn't
moonshine related at all" and was instead
"straight love."
"We were playing brothers.
There was a constant finger-in-the-ear [teasing]
thing going on for a while…it was all love.
I love the dude like a brother, straight up."
Jennie Garth and Shannen Doherty
These teen TV queens were on top of the world
when they shared the screen in Beverly Hills,
90210, but Jennie Garth and Shannen Doherty
had a very hard time getting along with each
other on the set.
In her 2014 tell-all book Deep Thoughts From
a Hollywood Blonde, Garth wrote:
"I don't know why it is, but there is a universal
truth that when you put three teenage girls
together, some serious s**t is going to go
down…there were times when we loved each
other and there were times when we wanted
to claw each other's eyes out."
In 2012, Shannen Doherty revealed that whatever
rivalry had developed between the pair had
since subsided, telling Glamour:
"I did the new 90210 with Jennie and there
was something very different about our friendship.
We were able to look at each other as grown
women and really acknowledge that we liked
who the other person was now as adults."
But as it turns out, you don't have to be
a teenage girl to want to smack your co-star.
You can be a golden one, too.
Bea Arthur and Betty White
Betty White is so likable that it's hard to
imagine anyone not wanting to become her best
friend.
Unfortunately, White's upbeat personality
didn't mesh well with co-star Bea Arthur during
the filming of their iconic sitcom The Golden
Girls.
White revealed during a 2013 panel discussion
with The New York Times:
"We were all close, but our personalities
were all so different.
[Bea] found me a pain in the neck sometimes
because [of] my positive attitude.
I'm happy all the time, and that made Bea
mad sometimes."
"Woah is me.
Woah."
"bad puppet."
Freddie Prinze Jr. and Kiefer Sutherland
Jack Bauer might have been a fan-favorite
superstar of the small screen, but Kiefer
Sutherland's co-star Freddie Prinze Jr. absolutely
despised working with the actor on the set
of 24.
He told ABC News:
"Kiefer was the most unprofessional dude in
the world.
That's not me talking trash, I'd say it to
his face, I think everyone that's worked with
him has said that."
Prinze's dislike for Sutherland extended so
far that he said he even considered quitting
show business after working with him.
Why was Prinze was so bothered by Sutherland?
For one, Prinze had to take his shoes off
to do scenes with him for the show, because
he was so much taller than Sutherland.
"Just put the guy on an apple box or don't
hire me next time.
You know I'm 6 feet and he's 5'4."
Hey, it could have been worse.
After all, this is Jack Bauer we're talking
about.
"I just watched my father die, and I felt
nothing."
Jeez.
Just take off your shoes, man.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!